Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 早上我觉得大家主要是讨论
Jake: This morning, I think everyone mainly discussed
Jake: 然后讨论的时候闲着没事
Jake: And while discussing, when there's nothing to do
Jake: 如果大家陷入了沉思
Jake: If everyone falls into deep thought
Jake: 陷入了尴尬
Jake: Or into awkwardness
Jake: 可以把这个给装一装
Jake: You can put this together
Jake: 对只是一个back up
Jake: Yeah, just as a backup
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 所以
Jake: So
Jake: 现在就尴尬了啊
Jake: Now it's awkward, huh
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no
Shure: 先看拆了看看是什么
Shure: Let's open it first and see what it is
Jake: 行那也行那也行
Jake: Okay, sure, that works too
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Lucia: 只有4个吗
Lucia: Only four?
Jake: 对只有4个
Jake: Yeah, only four
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay
Lucia: 我拆过这个
Lucia: I've done this before
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Jake: 因为你是menter
Jake: Because you're the mentor
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Oh, right
Jake: tutor
Jake: Tutor
Lucia: 哈哈我已经装过这个东西了
Lucia: Haha, I've already put this thing together before
Shure:  需要充电宝在这里拿
Shure: If you need a power bank, get it here
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Jake: 我先把这些端走
Jake: I'll take these away first
Katrina: 哇还有螺丝呀
Katrina: Wow, there are screws too
Jake: 大家拆出来了可以摆成什么样呢
Jake: Everyone, what can we arrange them into after taking them apart?
Jake: 摆成
Jake: Arrange them
Jake: 这个盒子要留着
Jake: We need to keep this box
Jake: 嗯里边这个东西可以丢掉
Jake: Hmm, the stuff inside can be thrown away
Jake: 这东西都丢掉吧
Jake: Let's throw all this stuff away
Jake: 这眼镜布留着
Jake: Keep this glasses cloth
Jake: 好 那就先摆成这样
Jake: Okay, let's arrange it like this for now
Jake: 这个是等大家陷入沉思的时候再用
Jake: We'll use this when everyone is deep in thought.
Jake: 但是这个我可以跟大家先讲一下
Jake: But let me explain this to you first.
Jake: 这个东西是什么呢
Jake: So, what is this thing?
Jake: 就大家可以看这个地方
Jake: Look at this spot here.
Jake: 你们也看不见这个地方
Jake: You can't see this spot either.
Jake: 或者你们过来吧
Jake: Or you can come over here.
Jake: 走动走动
Jake: Move around a bit.
Jake: 就是看我的工作间
Jake: Just take a look at my workspace.
Shure:  我们这算私闯闺房吗
Shure: Are we intruding into your private space?
Jake: 那请请请请
Jake: No, no, no, please come in.
Jake: 工作间
Jake: The workspace.
Jake: 然后这地方是一共有6台电脑对吧
Jake: So, there are a total of six computers here, right?
Jake: 然后这7台
Jake: And then there are seven.
Jake: 8台
Jake: Eight.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 9台 10台
Jake: Nine, ten.
Jake: 但是就是这边6台电脑
Jake: But there are six computers here.
Jake: 每一个电脑
Jake: Each computer.
Jake: 都对应着你们的一个一台眼镜
Jake: Corresponds to one of your glasses.
Jake: 然后这个每一台电脑
Jake: And each computer.
Jake: 你们每次录完结束
Jake: After each recording session.
Jake: 每隔三个小时
Jake: Every three hours.
Jake: 然后会嗯就是在这儿导到这个硬盘里边
Jake: It will be imported into this hard drive.
Jake: 然后这个硬盘
Jake: And this hard drive.
Jake: 就是你们一会要装的硬盘
Jake: Is the one you'll be installing later.
Jake: 就是比方说这个这个L1这个L1这个L2
Jake: For example, this L1, this L1, this L2.
Jake: 然后这个名字的名字都写在这了
Jake: The names are all written here.
Jake: 哈哈哈你们的数据都在这个里边
Jake: Haha, all your data is in here.
Shure:  这我们的第二生命
Shure: This is our second life.
Jake: 对你们的第二生命都在这个里边啊
Jake: Yes, your second life is all in here.
Jake: 比方说我这个L1
Jake: For example, my L1.
Jake: 对吧然后你们结束之后
Jake: Right, and after you're done.
Jake: 就是会把这个眼镜插到这个上面
Jake: You'll plug the glasses into this.
Jake: 然后同时
Jake: And at the same time,
Jake: 现在一直接着这个第一个硬盘
Jake: Now, connect this first hard drive.
Jake: 对然后这个硬盘它有两根线
Jake: Yeah, and this hard drive has two cables.
Jake: 一个是一个是接电脑的
Jake: One is for connecting to the computer,
Jake: 一个是接电源的
Jake: And one is for power.
Jake: 然后这个电源
Jake: Then the power,
Jake: 是为了让这个硬盘假装自己在电脑上
Jake: Is to make the hard drive think it's connected to a computer.
Jake:呵呵 所以这个盒的意思就是说
Jake: Haha, so this box means,
Jake: 他给模拟一个电脑的环境
Jake: It simulates a computer environment.
Shure: 诱骗器
Shure: A decoy.
Jake: 然后用硬盘对对
Jake: And then the hard drive, yeah, yeah,
Jake: 让硬盘能知道自己要工作了
Jake: Yeah, so the hard drive knows it needs to work.
Jake: 对啊然后这个线啊
Jake: Yeah, and then this cable,
Jake: 这个线我们我们布线还挺有意思的
Jake: Our wiring is pretty interesting.
Jake: 就长成这个样子
Jake: It looks like this.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 是一个悬着的啊
Shure: It's kind of hanging, huh?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 那如果突然停电了会怎么样
Shure: What if the power suddenly goes out?
Jake: 那不好讲
Jake: That’s hard to say.
Jake: 就是电脑突然停电
Jake: Like if the computer suddenly loses power.
Jake: 就是会很尴尬
Jake: It would be really awkward.
Shure:  那没有什么
Shure: Is there anything like...
Shure:  就是USB之类的
Shure: Like a USB or something?
Shure:  嗯就是那种备用电源
Shure: Like a backup power source?
Jake: 哦哦没有
Jake: Oh, no.
Jake: 还没那么有钱
Jake: We’re not that rich yet.
Jake: 我们只能相信这个别墅
Jake: We just have to trust this villa.
Jake: 或者相信北京电力吧
Jake: Or trust the Beijing power grid.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  感谢
Shure: Thanks.
Jake: 好你们都开始装了
Jake: Okay, are you all starting to install?
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  我们可以
Shure: We can...
Jake:可以边聊边装嘛
Jake: We can chat while installing, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 嗯或者说你们先带你们带了什么嘛
Jake: Yeah, or maybe you guys should bring something first.
Jake: 你们带了什么
Jake: What did you bring?
Jake: 哎这个这个眼镜你得带好
Jake: Hey, these glasses, you need to wear them properly.
Jake: 这眼镜
Jake: These glasses...
Jake: 嗯也不能遮住
Jake: Yeah, you shouldn't cover them.
Jake: 应该都不没遮住吧
Jake: They shouldn't be covered, right?
Jake: 现在没遮住
Jake: They aren't covered now.
Lucia:  但这里有一个孔
Jake: But there's a hole here.
Lucia: 然后这个地方是要坐在这的
Lucia: And this part needs to sit here.
Lucia: 所以你要就是最好这样对齐
Lucia: So you need to align it like this.
Lucia: 然后慢慢往里推
Lucia: And then slowly push it in.
Lucia: 看怎么样能推进去
Lucia: See how you can push it in.
Lucia: 好像要轻一点
Lucia: It needs to be gentle.
Lucia: 那天那同学跟我说这个挺脆弱的
Lucia: That classmate told me it's quite fragile.
Jake: 嗯对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake: 没事搞定
Jake: No worries, we got this.
Lucia: 就是这不是有一个口吗
Lucia: There's a slot here, right?
Lucia: 跟这个是对着的
Lucia: It aligns with this.
Lucia: 你就像他们这样对着
Lucia: Just align it like this.
Lucia: 然后慢慢地推
Lucia: And then push it slowly.
Lucia: 看这样手里能有推进去
Lucia: See if you can push it in with your hands.
Lucia: 要稍微使点力气
Lucia: You need to use a bit of force.
Lucia: 他这还是有一点紧的
Lucia: It's still a bit tight.
Lucia: 但是需要别太使劲
Shure: But don't use too much force.
Lucia: 别掰坏了
Lucia: Don't break it.
Shure:  没有吧
Shure: It shouldn't be, right?
Lucia: 好像很脆弱的样子
Lucia: It looks really fragile.
Lucia: 不过我其实也不是很懂这个
Lucia: But I don't really understand this.
Jake: 有有有很多螺丝
Jake: There are lots of screws.
Lucia: 要拧螺丝
Lucia: Need to tighten the screws.
Jake: 对
Shure: 那螺丝呢
Shure: Where's the screw?
Lucia: 在那里面
Lucia: It's in there
Shure:  哦懂了
Jake: Oh, got it
Shure:  easy
Shure: Easy
Katrina:  然后就把它装进去了
Katrina: And then just install it
Lucia: 嗯对然后要装到这个盒子里
Lucia: Yeah, and then put it in this box
Lucia: 就是你最好是把这个地方取下来
Lucia: It’s best if you remove this part
Lucia: 然后这个片就可以不要了
Lucia: Then you won't need this piece
Lucia: 因为这里一会要也要用来拧螺丝
Lucia: Because you'll need to screw here later
Alice: 是不是只要拧4个螺丝
Alice: Do we only need to screw in 4 screws?
Lucia: 呃8个
Lucia: Uh, 8
Alice:8个吗
Alice: 8?
Lucia: 对
Lucia:Right
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Lucia: 就是你你把那个条抽出来
Lucia: You just need to pull out that strip.
Lucia: 对然后就你看到那个孔了没
Lucia: Right, and you see that hole?
Lucia: 长条形那个
Lucia: The long rectangular one.
Lucia: 他那里面也有一个螺丝孔
Lucia: There's a screw hole inside there too.
Lucia: 你要把那个也上上
Lucia: You need to screw that one in as well.
Lucia: 就是那个是大螺丝的螺丝孔
Lucia: That’s the screw hole for the big screw.
Tasha: 啊哪个
Katrina: Uh, which one?
Lucia: 呃这一个
Lucia: Uh, this one.
Alice:我已经上上完一个螺丝
Alice: I’ve already screwed one in here.
Lucia: 就是这个这个东西
Lucia: It’s this thing.
Lucia: 嗯我怎么样给你指的比较清楚
Lucia: Hmm, how can I show you more clearly?
Lucia: 哎你上的这是对的
Lucia: Yeah, you got this one right.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 对然后这边每个都有
Lucia: Yeah, and there’s one in each of these.
Lucia: 然后这个也是所以一共是8个
Lucia: And this one too, so there are 8 in total.
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: That’s right.
Alice:嗷懂了
Alice: Oh, got it.
Alice: 看见了
Alice: I see it.
Katrina: 这是大螺丝
Katrina:It's the big screw.
Katrina:  你看在这
Katrina: Look, it's here.
Lucia: 对对小螺丝上这对
Lucia: Right, on the small screws.
Alice: 哦里边是把它插进去就行了吧
Alice: Oh, just insert it inside, right?
Alice: 就那个
Alice: Just that one.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 呃那个对
Alice: Uh, that one, right.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 里面应该插进去
Lucia: It should be inserted inside.
Alice: 集成电路还是什么
Alice:  Integrated circuit or something?
Jake: 上一回我们一直在抱怨磁吸的问题
Jake: Last time, we kept complaining about the magnet issue.
Jake: 但是好像今天大家都没有什么
Jake: But it seems like today, nobody has any...
Lucia: 对今天大家好像接受良好
Jake: Yeah, today, everyone seems to be fine with it.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 什么磁吸
Alice:  What magnet thing?
Shure:  毕毕竟附赠的这个不可能给你
Shure: After all, the freebie can't possibly give you...
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Exactly, exactly.
Lucia: 这个螺丝刀它没有磁吸
Lucia: This screwdriver doesn't have a magnet.
Lucia: 对所以就是在这是装大的
Lucia: So yeah, it's for the bigger ones.
Lucia: 放螺丝的时候就很麻
Lucia: When placing screws, it's a hassle.
Lucia: 对是这里是放大的
Lucia: Yeah, here, it's for the big ones.
Katrina:  嗯大的能卡进去
Katrina: Mm-hmm, the big ones can fit in.
Lucia: 呃他就是这样子
Lucia: Uh, it's like this.
Lucia: 他没有办法就穿过这个孔
Lucia: It can't pass through this hole.
Lucia: 你就是要把
Lucia: You just need to...
Jake:你的头发总喜欢挡着镜头
Jake: Your hair always covers the camera.
Jake: 要不想想办法
Jake: How about we think of a way?
Tasha: 这个吗？
Jake: 对或者塞到里边去
Jake: Yeah, or stuff it inside.
Tasha: 我塞了一道
Lucia: 大家是只要把它固定住就好
Lucia: Everyone just needs to secure it.
Lucia: 是是这样吗
Lucia: Is that right?
Jake: 对
Jake:
Jake: 嗯这个好
Jake: Hmm, this is good.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  是不是可以有一点BGM
Shure: Can we have a bit of BGM?
Lucia: 支持
Lucia: I agree.
Jake:让你放一点喂
Jake: For you to play a bit.
Alice: 我来
Shure:  大家平时爱听什么类型的音乐
Shure: What kind of music do you all usually like to listen to?
Katrina:  我我听陶喆
Katrina: I, I listen to David Tao.
Jake: 陶喆类型的音乐
Jake: David Tao type of music.
Jake: 嗯RMB RMB
Jake: Hmm, RMB, RMB.
Lucia: 我是混欧美圈的
Lucia: Mixing in the Western circles.
Lucia: 所以就乱听
Lucia: So I listen to random stuff.
Alice: 给大家一个比较干劲的
Alice: Give everyone something with more energy.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay,
Katrina:  弹那个东北御姐的BGM
Katrina:  play that Northeastern Domineering Lady BGM.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina:Hahahaha.
Jake:来自东方
Jake: From the East.
Alice: 干活的时候必须贼有劲
Alice: When working, it has to be super energetic.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 来跳吧要不然
Jake: Come on, let's dance then.
Shure:  我想扛起来了
Shure: I feel like lifting it up.
Shure:  这个半嵌入就行是吧
Shure: Hahaha, this half-embedding is fine, right?
Shure:  这样
Shure: Like this.
Jake: 对对古蔺游戏
Jake: Yeah, yeah, Gulian game.
Shure: 大东北 我的家乡
Shure: Great Northeast, my hometown.
Jake: 你东北哪的呀
Jake: Which part of the Northeast are you from?
Shure: 我 稻花香
Shure: I'm from Daohuaxiang.
Jake: 东北稻花的
Jake: The rice fields of the Northeast?
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  那个长春的
Shure: I'm from Changchun.
Jake: 长春的
Jake: Changchun.
Shure: 吉林省长春市
Shure: Jilin Province, Changchun City.
Shure:  大家知道这个城市吗
Shure: Do you guys know this city?
Katrina: 知道呀
Katrina: Yes, I do.
Shure:  大家知道吉林省还有个吉林市吗
Shure: Do you guys know there's also a Jilin City in Jilin Province?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:对这也知道
Jake: Yeah, I know that too.
Jake: 怎么你在吉林市
Jake: So, are you in Jilin City?
Jake: 没有我在吉林市
Jake:  No, I'm in Jilin City.
Jake: 你们隔壁
Jake: Next to you guys.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure:  好像是
Jake: Seems like it.
Shure:  大东北
Shure: Great Northeast.
Shure:  AI人类为什么喜欢听这样的音乐
Shure: AI, why do humans like listening to this kind of music?
Lucia: 人类迷惑行为
Lucia: Human confusion behavior.
Jake: 然后这边有一个螺丝
Jake: And then there's a screw over here.
Jake: 你看两边
Jake: Look at both sides.
Lucia: 外面这好像不装回去也
Lucia: It seems like we don't have to put it back outside.
Lucia: 也可以就这个条
Lucia: We can just leave this strip.
Lucia: 我们那天反正好像都扔了我记得
Lucia: I remember we threw them away that day anyway.
Shure:  这条可以扔
Shure: This strip can be thrown away.
Lucia: 这条可以可以任意摆
Lucia: This strip can be placed anywhere.
Jake: 可以放可以放
Jake: This strip can be placed anywhere.
Jake: 我昨天成功的放了进去
Jake: I successfully placed it inside yesterday.
Lucia: 哦哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh oh oh, I see.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 那那那咱那天的嘞
Lucia: Then, what about that day?
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 它就是美观
Jake: It's just for aesthetics.
Jake: 它就是看的没有螺丝
Jake: It looks better without screws.
Jake: 然后把它这样
Jake: Then, like this.
Shure: 可以进厂了
Shure: It can enter the venue.
Alice: 可以我已经进过厂了
Alice: Yes, I have already entered the venue.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 啊你你进过厂玩过
Jake: Ah, you've been to the venue before?
Alice: 我觉得我们大学那些接线的
Alice: I think those wiring tasks we did in college...
Alice: 焊板子的跟进厂没啥区别
Alice: ...were no different from entering the factory.
Jake: 物联网吗
Jake: Internet of Things?
Jake: 还是什么
Jake: Or what?
Tasha: 就这样吗
Alice: 对电工
Alice: Yes, electricians.
Lucia: 看吧对电工实习会做一些神奇的东西 我们学校也是
Lucia: Look, electrician internships let you do some amazing things. Our school too.
Jake: 最后最后放成这个样子
Jake: Finally, finally it turns out like this.
Jake: 好吧然后就就可以出叫出厂了对
Jake: Alright, then it can be called finished, right?
Jake: 出流水线
Jake: Off the assembly line.
Jake: 下一个流水线
Jake: Next assembly line.
Lucia: 下一个流水线是让你接到电脑上的
Lucia: The next assembly line connects to the computer.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  下一个需要高级技工
Shure: The next one needs skilled workers.
Lucia: 哈哈哈高级技工
Lucia: Hahaha, skilled workers.
Alice: 查查的
Alice: Check it.
Jake: 3,000的技工到5,000的技工
Jake: A technician from 3,000 to 5,000.
Shure:  你说的这是技工吗
Shure: Are you talking about a technician?
Alice: 什么是技工
Alice: Who is Ji Gong?
Lucia: 技术工人
Lucia: a technical worker.
Alice: 鸡公煲
Alice: Ji Gong Bao,
Lucia: 技术工人
Lucia: a technical worker.
Shure:  哎为什么我
Shure: Why me?
Alice: 因为你按反了啊
Alice: Because you pressed it the wrong way!
Jake: 这个是有俩螺丝啊
Jake: This has two screws, huh?
Shure:  嗐
Shure: hey.
Jake:嗐
Jake: hey.
Shure:  完了太丢人了
Shure: Oh no, this is so embarrassing.
Jake: 2,000的
Jake: 2,000.
Shure: 倒数第一了
Shure: Last place.
Jake:2,000了
Jake: 2,000.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 不行我必须要争一下
Shure: No way, I have to try again.
Shure:  我不能倒数第一
Shure: I can't be last.
Jake: 哈哈好
Shure: Haha, okay.
Jake: 硬盘硬盘锦标赛
Jake: Hard drive, hard drive tournament.
Katrina: 就不用干什么了吗
Katrina：So we don't have to do anything?
Lucia: 拧完应该就就好了
Lucia: Tighten it, and it should be good.
Shure:  嗐 他风轻云淡的说一句拧完了
Shure: Yeah, he just casually says it's tightened.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  他挑衅我
Shure: He's taunting me.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jake:到底还有机会吗
Jake: Is there still a chance?
Katrina:  是这样吗
Katrina: Is it like this?
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: I guess so.
Jake: 对对对放到这个盒子里面
Jake: Yes, yes, put it in this box.
Shure:  你看你没有装上那一关
Jake: Look, you didn't install that part.
Jake: 对条不用装这就是最后一步
Jake: No need to install the bar, this is the last step.
Jake: 给你一点机会但是你还是没有抓住
Jake: Gave you a chance but you still didn't catch it.
Lucia: 你可以把条放在里面
Lucia: You can put the bar inside.
Lucia: 如果需要装的话
Lucia: If it needs to be installed.
Lucia: 然后尽量自己装就好了
Lucia: Then try to do it yourself.
Jake: 没需要装完全没必要放里面就好
Jake: No need to install, just put it inside.
Shure:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Shure:  他已经可以出厂了
Shure: He can go on stage now,
Jake: 出厂 好谢谢大家
Jake: Alright, thank you everyone.
Jake: 完成了一个奇怪的第一次任务
Jake: Go on stage.completed a weird first task.
Jake: 然后这个EGO life最后一天
Jake: And this is the last day of EGO life.
Jake: 大家会邀请什么人呢
Jake: Who will everyone invite?
Shure:  啊最后一天
Shure: Ah, the last day.
Jake: 最后一天
Jake: The last day.
Shure: 是周日是吗
Shure: It's Sunday, right?
Jake: 是周周日周日下午吧
Jake: It's Sunday, Sunday afternoon, right?
Shure:  啊咱俩会邀请什么人
Shure: Ah, who will we invite?
Jake: 会邀请几个人
Jake: We'll invite a few people.
Jake: 呀
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 应该
Lucia: Should be.
Shure: 黑板写一写吧
Shure: Write it on the blackboard.
Jake: 对黑板可以写一写
Jake: Yes, you can write it on the blackboard.
Shure:  来我来我字非常好看
Jake: Let me do it, my writing is very nice.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我们还有一个架子
Jake: We have another shelf.
Jake: 要不我们也拼一拼
Jake: How about we assemble it too?
Shure:  什么架子
Shure: What shelf?
Jake:就是不是
Jake:  Like, no.
Jake: 你如果觉得这个这么写很难写的话
Jake: If you think it's hard to write like this.
Jake: 它其实有一个
Jake: Actually, there's a...
Shure:  有笔吗
Jake: 就这个东西就是你可以
Jake: You can just pretend to
Shure:  假装再装吧
Jake: 行问题不大是吧
Shure: Sure, it's not a big deal, right?
Shure:  问题不大
Jake: Not a big deal.
Jake:问题不大
Shure:  不影响我这个书法的发挥
Shure: It won't affect my calligraphy performance.
Jake: 笔呢
Jake: Pen?
Shure: 笔呢
Shure: Pen?
Shure: 好问题
Shure: Good question.
Jake:好问题
Jake: Good question.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  问问他问问AI
Shure: Ask him, ask AI.
Shure:  笔呢
Shure: Pen?
Jake:笔呢
Jake: Pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的iPhone吗
Lucia: Looking for my iPhone?
Jake: 哈哈哈对笔呢
Jake: Hahaha, yes, pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的
Lucia: Looking for my...
Lucia: 寻找我的pencil
Lucia: Looking for my pencil.
Jake: 笔应该在上面
Jake: The pen should be up there.
Jake: 等一下啊
Jake: Wait a second.
Shure:  我们都是iPhone
Shure: We all have iPhones.
Lucia: 好像应该是
Lucia: Seems like we should.
Alice: 我是ePhone
Alice: I'm an ePhone.
Shure:  咦什么烂梗啊哈哈哈
Shure: What a lame joke, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊这是个梗吗
Lucia: Ah, is this a joke?
Lucia: 我为什么没有改到iPhone
Lucia: Why didn't I switch to iPhone?
Katrina:  他是e人
Katrina: He's an ePerson.
Lucia: 哦哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 哎所以我们的一人到底是哪两位啊
Lucia: So, who are the two ePersons among us?
Jake: 一
Jake: One...
Katrina:  我
Shure: 我我也是一
Shure: Yeah, I'm also a one.
Lucia: 哎你是一吗
Lucia: Hey, are you a one?
Shure:  啊我我是E不是1啊OK
Shure: Ah, I'm an E, not a one, OK.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:有啥差别啊
Jake: What's the difference?
Jake: 啊你是1哦
Jake: Oh, you're a one.
Lucia:所以哎那我们是6啊
Lucia: So, hey, that makes us a six.
Katrina:  算算一两
Katrina: Count, count, one, two.
Lucia: 哎那咱俩是然后呢
Lucia: So, we're a pair, then what?
Lucia: 啊OK昨天我没有
Lucia: Ah, OK, I didn't...
Lucia: 昨天我没有猜出来
Lucia: Yesterday, I didn't guess it.
Lucia: 虽然我猜到他可能是E人
Lucia: Although I guessed that he might be an E person.
Shure: EGO life
Shure: EGO life.
Shure:  最后一天的名单行啊
Shure: The final day's list is fine.
Shure:  你
Shure: You...
Shure:  喵
Shure: Meow.
Jake:哈哈是这么写的
Jake: Haha, is that how you write it?
Shure:  11是这么写的
Shure: 11 Is that how you write it?
Jake: 是这么写的
Shure:  夹怎么写
Shure: How do you write "夹"?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 啊太久没写
Shure: Ah, it's been too long since I wrote it.
Tasha: 宝盖头
Tasha: 宝盖头,
Katrina: 宝盖头
Katrina: 宝盖头.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  OK第一位
Shure: OK, the first one.
Jake: 修硕你邀请几个人啊
Jake: Shure, how many people did you invite?
Shure:  我浅浅邀一个吧
Shure: I'll just invite one.
Jake: 浅浅浅先邀一个啊
Jake:Just one for now.
Jake: 露亚呢
Jake: What about Lucy?
Lucia: 我不太确定因为咱们这太远了
Lucia: I'm not sure because it's too far.
Lucia: 我不知道我小伙伴过不过得来
Lucia: I don't know if my friend can make it.
Jake: 好那你的工作是
Jake: Okay, so your studio...
Tasha: 我浅浅邀请一个吧
Tasha: I'll lightly invite someone.
Jake: 好浅浅邀请一个
Jake: Lightly invite someone, sure.
Shure:  叫什么名字
Shure: What's the name?
Jake: 用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake: 这就用不
Jake: No need for that.
Jake: 就是大概画个正字得了
Jake: Just draw a tally mark, that'll do.
Shure:  啊画正字好
Shure: Ah, a tally mark, okay.
Jake: 或者你用那个小球
Jake: Or use that little ball.
Jake: 我估计也够
Jake: I think it should be enough.
Katrina:  画小人吧
Katrina: Draw little people.
Katrina:  男生就是这样
Katrina: Boys are like this.
Katrina:  女生夹两边
Katrina: Girls on both sides.
Shure:  你邀请
Shure: You invite.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这是你邀请的女生吗
Tasha: Is this the girl you invited?
Tasha: 啊你啊
Tasha: Ah, you...
Tasha: 那我也邀请一位女生
Tasha: Then I'll invite a girl too.
Lucia: 你这个你这个辫
Lucia: Your... your braid...
Lucia: 他这个接口没有在头上
Lucia: His connection isn't on the head.
Katrina:  这个假发我的天呐
Katrina: This wig, oh my god.
Shure: 我们冲天一下哎
Shure: Let's aim for the sky.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 我应该邀请一个男生
Katrina: I should invite a guy.
Shure:  男生
Shure: A guy.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice: 我爱心童的
Alice: I love kids.
Katrina: 哈哈三条腿
Katrina: Hahaha, three legs.
Jake: 哈哈哈这合适吧这样
Jake: Hahaha, this works, right?
Shure:  对不起不小心画出头
Shure: Sorry, accidentally drew the head.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: OK
Lucia: 我其实可以问一个女生
Lucia: I actually can ask a girl.
Lucia: 但我不确定她能不能过得来
Lucia: But I'm not sure if she can come.
Lucia: 因为她那边挺远的
Lucia: Because it's quite far for her.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈存疑是吧存疑
Lucia: Hahaha, doubtful, right? Doubtful.
Jake: 还有你可以在每个人下面写一个名字
Jake: And you can write a name under each person.
Jake: 写一个他的host
Jake: Write down their host.
Shure:  host是吗
Shure: Host, right?
Jake: 嗯就是你的代号嘛
Jake: Yeah, it's your code name.
Shure:  嗯认领一下
Shure: Yeah, claim it.
Jake: 不不不
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 你就在这个小人的下面写一个
Jake: Just write it under this little person.
Jake: 或者在上面或者脸上写一个之类的
Jake: Or above it, or on the face, something like that.
Shure:  这是谁的来着那
Shure: Whose is this again?
Katrina:  呃塔莎
Katrina: Uh, it's his, it's his.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Alice:这是宇轩的
Alice: This is Yuxuan's.
Katrina:  嗯那写LX LYX
Katrina: Hmm, then write LX, LYX.
Jake: 啊哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha
Shure:  这这位是谁的人
Shure: Whose person is this?
Lucia: 我露西或者写个l也行哈哈哈
Shure: I can record or just write an "L", hahaha.
Shure:  啊你要邀请两个是吗
Shure: Ah, are you going to invite the prize?
Alice: 对但是有一个可能来不了
Alice: Yes, but one might not come.
Shure:  性别
Shure: Gender?
Alice: 都是女的呵
Alice: They're all girls, huh.
Alice: 有一个不知道能来不能
Alice: One might not be able to come.
Alice: 你给我画个星就行了五角星
Alice: Just draw me a star, a five-pointed star.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Shure:  现在我们有一二三四五六六位嘉宾
Shure: Now we have one, two, three, four, five, six, six guests.
Jake: 嗯呃4-6位嘉宾
Jake: Hmm, uh, 4-6 guests.
Shure:  对 4-6位
Shure: Right, 4-6 guests.
Jake:4-6位嘉宾OK
Jake: 4-6 guests, OK.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake: 我们原来还打算有可能的话
Jake: We were originally planning, if possible,
Jake: 去邀请周围的人
Jake: to invite people from around.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 就是或者小红书
Jake: Or use Xiaohongshu (Little Red Book).
Jake: 还是
Lucia: Or...
Lucia: 是采取挨家挨户敲门询问的方式吗
Lucia: Are we going to knock on doors and ask?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Tasha: 提一篮子鸡蛋比较好
Tasha: Bringing a basket of eggs is better.
Jake: 环球影城门口直接抓人鸡蛋比较好
Jake: Bringing a basket of eggs is better.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 确实如果如
Lucia: Indeed, if...
Lucia: 果就是如果他们来的话可以发鸡蛋什么的
Lucia: if they come, we can give out eggs or something.
Lucia: 听起来就像香肠一样
Lucia: It sounds like sausages.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  明天咱们这就被举报了
Shure: Tomorrow, our show will get reported.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 明天可以拍一段警察的镜头哈哈哈
Jake: Tomorrow, we can shoot a scene with the police. Hahaha.
Shure:  哎这邀字好难写
Shure: Ugh, this "invite" character is hard to write.
Jake: 要不以Y字吧
Jake: How about using a simpler character?
Shure:  我觉得也是
Shure: I think so too.
Tasha: 带上鸡蛋
Tasha: Tie it up.
Tasha: 你要是来我就把这一篮送你
Tasha: If you come, I'll give you this basket.
Tasha: 你不来就不送
Tasha: If you don't come, no eggs for you.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  邻居
Shure: Home.
Shure:  哎这字
Shure: Ugh, this character...
Shure:  齐白石看着都落泪
Shure: Even Qi Baishi would be in tears looking at this.
Alice: 有种复古的感觉
Alice: It has a retro feel.
Shure:  这是我们的plan
Shure: This is our plan.
Shure:  存疑plan
Shure: A questionable plan.
Shure:  okay
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 好多问号啊
Lucia: So many question marks.
Lucia: 我们好像谜语人
Lucia: We look like riddlers.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: the riddle
Shure: The riddle.
Shure:  然后我们还还有
Shure: And then we still have...
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else do we have?
Jake: 呃这是人员
Jake: Uh, this is the personnel.
Shure:  不对
Shure: No.
Jake: 呃剧组吧剧组还有5个人
Jake: Uh, the crew, the crew still has 5 people.
Jake: 然后对总共看
Jake: And then, yes, overall...
Jake: 最后我们要host多少个人
Jake: Finally, how many people do we need to host?
Jake: 然后看看这活动在这个人数下
Jake: Then let's see what we should do with this number of people.
Jake: 应该整点啥
Jake: What should we do?
Alice:: 缴丝
Jake: 给大家拍
Jake: Took a picture for everyone.
Lucia: 这没事没事可以技术处理一下吗
Jake: Can we fix this technically?
Jake: 是但是后期给后期很麻烦
Jake: Yes, but it's a hassle for post-production.
Shure: 后期给
Shure: For post-production.
Shure:  添了多少麻烦
Shure: How much trouble did we add?
Shure:  OK所以总共one two three four
Shure: OK, so in total, one, two, three, four.
Tasha: 4到6 个
Tasha: 4 to 6.
Shure: four加五五个
Shure: Four plus five, five people.
Shure:  这是9
Shure: That's 9.
Jake:4加五九
Jake: 4 plus 59
Jake: 九到11是吧
Jake: 999 to 11, right?
Shure:  9到11 人
Shure: 9 to 11 people
Jake: 9到11 然后各位自己
Jake: 9 to 11, then everyone
Shure:  算算上我们是吧
Shure: Including us, right?
Jake:可以 哎就先先先就写到9-11吧
Jake: Okay, let's just write down 9 to 11 for now.
Jake: 9-11
Jake: 9 to 11
Shure: 9-11 徒正无穷
Shure: 9 to 11, endless potential
Shure:  因为我们可以邀请邻居
Shure: Because we can invite the neighbors
Jake: 嗯对对
Jake: Yeah, right
Shure:  嗯对对
Jake: 非常也有无穷的邻居
Jake: We do have a lot of neighbors
Jake: 也不是正无穷吧 16亿
Jake: But not exactly boundless, more like 1.6 billion
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure:  现在我们我我国人有16亿了吗
Shure: Do we have 1.6 billion people in our country now?
Jake: 14
Jake: 1.4
Shure: 14吧
Shure: 1.4, right?
Jake:那就14
Jake: Let's go with 1.4
Shure:  完了这移动的
Shure: Alright, this is mobile
Jake:报数多了
Jake: Too many numbers
Jake: 哈哈合适吗
Jake: Haha, is it appropriate?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Jake: 问题不大问题不大
Jake: No big deal, no big deal
Shure:  一OK
Shure: One OK
Jake: OK
Shure:  然后好人员确定了
Shure: Alright, personnel is confirmed
Shure:  嗯这是第一
Shure: Yeah, that's the first
Shure:  第一大点的第三
Shure: First main point, third
Shure:  下面三个小点人员
Shure: Now the three sub-points about personnel
Shure:  然后我们还有第二点
Shure: And then we have the second point
Shure:  要开始活
Shure: To start the work
Shure:  动内容部分吗
Shure: About the content part?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure:  这我觉得是一块硬骨头我们要啃很久
Shure: I think this is a tough nut to crack, it's gonna take us a while.
Shure:  嗯所以我们要直接先来这个吗
Shure: Hmm, so should we start with this?
Jake: 那还有别的吗
Jake: Do we have anything else?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  活动内容
Shure: Event content.
Shure:  大家想想
Shure: Everyone, think about it.
Shure:  我记得大家问卷的时候应该是填过的
Shure: I remember everyone filled out the questionnaire, right?
Shure:  嗯是吧
Shure: Hmm, right?
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 大家问卷填的是什么来着
Shure: What did everyone write on the questionnaire?
Shure:  不会都是GPT生成的吧
Shure: They weren't all generated by GPT, right?
Katrina:  不是哈哈哈我自己写的
Katrina: No, hahaha, I wrote it myself.
Jake: 湖南GPT生成的
Jake: I wrote it myself, generated by Hunan GPT.
Shure:  那既然提到湖南这笔题那我们先从
Shure: Since you mentioned Hunan, let's start with that.
Shure:  Lyx同学
Shure: Lyx.
Katrina:  我我想是那个就是呃7天
Katrina: Hahaha, I think it's that, uh, 7 days.
Katrina:  然后每我买那花嘛
Katrina: And then each person gets a flower.
Katrina:  然后每人一个花瓶
Katrina: And a vase for each person.
Katrina:  然后就相当于醒花一一到2天
Katrina: So the flower can bloom for one to two days.
Katrina:  然后刚好他一个周期
Katrina: Just in time for its cycle.
Katrina:  就是可以让这花慢慢的开放
Katrina: So the flower can slowly bloom.
Katrina:  然后把这个花的花瓣
Katrina: Then we can press the flower petals.
Katrina:  然后做成那种压花
Katrina: To make pressed flower crafts.
Katrina:  然后就比较环保做成那种明信片
Katrina: Then it's more eco-friendly to make postcards.
Katrina:  还有买了那种亚克力的玻璃
Katrina: And I bought some acrylic glass.
Katrina:  然后就嵌进去
Katrina: Then we embed them.
Katrina:  就是那种比较好看的手工
Katrina: To make beautiful crafts.
Katrina:  然后也跟植物有关
Katrina: Also related to plants.
Katrina:  然后原材料又是自己精心养了7天的
Katrina: And the raw materials are carefully nurtured for 7 days.
Katrina:  然后又觉得形成了一个闭环
Katrina: So it forms a complete cycle.
Jake: 好
Jake: Good.
Katrina: 就做了一些周边
Katrina: Just made some peripherals.
Katrina:  到时候那一天就可以分发给大家
Katrina: On that day, we can distribute them to everyone.
Jake: 上才艺
Jake: Showcase talent.
Katrina:  那花的在哪
Katrina: Where are the flowers?
Katrina:  花还要醒的
Katrina: The flowers need to wake up.
Katrina:  因为我看我
Katrina: Because I saw...
Katrina:  我刚才想的是种那种什么东西
Katrina: I was just thinking about planting something.
Katrina:  符合那种地球世界
Katrina: Something fitting for the Earth.
Katrina:  地球日他7天基本上发不了芽
Katrina: Earth Day is in 7 days, and it won't sprout by then.
Katrina:  然后我就想是买这种花
Katrina: So I thought of buying these flowers.
Jake:上才艺
Jake: Showcase talent.
Katrina: 直接那个顺丰发过来
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is that it?
Katrina:  云南的花
Katrina: Flowers from Yunnan.
Katrina:  是
Lucia: 他好像有两个苞
Lucia: It seems like it has two buds.
Katrina:  对我买了芍药啊
Katrina: Yeah, I bought peonies.
Shure: 不想送了
Shure: Don't want to give them away.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  刚好一些花骨朵就这两天就可以开了
Katrina: Just in time, some flower buds can bloom in these two days.
Lucia: 你要找个剪刀什么的吗
Lucia: Do you need to find scissors or something?
Alice: 剪刀
Alice: Scissors.
Katrina:  直接开始干吗还是说要把后面的列完
Katrina: JK Gan, or do we need to list the rest?
Jake: 呃先秀一下
Jake: Uh, show it off first.
Shure: 先秀一下
Shure: Show it off first.
Jake:先秀一下
Jake: Show it off first.
Alice: 剪刀在哪
Alice: The scissors are missing.
Katrina:  我买了好几束来着
Katrina: I bought several bunches.
Shure: 剪刀在这儿呢
Shure: The scissors are here.
Katrina: 还买了康乃馨
Katrina: I also bought carnations.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake: 眼神好啊小伙
Jake: Good eyes, young man.
Katrina:  刚好我们女孩子比较多哈哈
Alice: Just right, we have more girls here, haha.
Katrina:  啊这也是
Katrina: Ah, that's true.
Katrina:  这花瓣就可以做压花
Katrina: These petals can be used for pressed flowers.
Katrina:  然后买了压花器还有那种干燥剂
Katrina: So, I bought a flower press and some desiccant.
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What's this?
Katrina:  这些花这个要养一下
Katrina: This is a flower, it needs to be aired out.
Alice: 这是芍药吗
Tasha: Is this a peony?
Katrina:  嗯我买多了我才知道
Alice: Hmm, I only realized I bought too many.
Katrina:  他说要一到两天才能开花
Katrina: He said it takes one to two days to bloom.
Katrina:  然后想时间就差不多
Katrina: So, I think the timing is just right.
Katrina:  压花就要压两三天
Katrina: Pressed flowers need to be pressed for two to three days.
Katrina:  然后这个养个两三天
Katrina: Then, this needs to be maintained for two to three days.
Lucia: 这是什么百合
Lucia: What kind of lily is this?
Alice:香雪蓝还是啥
Alice: Freesia or something?
Katrina:  什么百合来着百合蓝
Katrina: What kind of lily, lily blue?
Tasha: 营养剂泡在水里面加速醒花的
Tasha: Nutrients soaked in water speed up the awakening process.
Alice: 这两个颜色的
Alice: These two colors.
Katrina:  对一个白一个黄
Katrina: Yeah, one white and one yellow.
Katrina:  是一个包裹
Katrina: It's one package.
Katrina:  我看我记得他好像发两个包裹
Katrina: I remember he sent two packages.
Jake: 要不他上我们也上
Jake: If he's going, we should go too.
Jake: 才艺你看看哪些是你的
Jake: Talent show, see which ones are yours.
Tasha: 没有我的
Tasha: None are mine.
Jake: 没有你的啊
Jake: None of yours?
Jake: 你没有买这个
Jake: You didn't buy this one?
Jake: 外面的快递就只有雨轩的是吧
Jake: The only package outside is Yuxuan's, right?
Jake: 还有别人买快递
Jake: There are other people ordering deliveries.
Lucia: 你们买东西了吗
Lucia: Did you guys buy anything?
Shure:  还没呢还没
Shure: Not yet, not yet.
Jake: 行没问题
Jake: Okay, no problem.
Jake: 塔莎都是自带的是吧
Jake: He brings his own materials, right?
Shure:  带资进组
Shure: He funds his own projects.
Shure:  你看这就
Shure: Look at this, it just...
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 觉悟
Shure: Enlightening.
Katrina:  然后呢
Katrina: So then,
Jake: 然后 就
Jake: So
Jake: 比划比划
Jake: Demonstrate it.
Katrina:  花瓶
Jake: 就是大概要个什么形式
Jake: So, what kind of format are we going for?
Katrina: 形式吗 形式就是我们6个人一人一个花瓶
Katrina: Format? The format is, there are six of us, each gets a vase.
Katrina:  我也买好了
Katrina: I've already bought the vases.
Katrina:  然后大家把这花分分分分了以后养了
Katrina: Then everyone will split the flowers and take care of them.
Katrina:  一一一到两三天
Katrina: After one or two days...
Katrina:  呃他这个就会慢慢全部开了嘛
Katrina: Uh, they will slowly start to bloom.
Katrina:  开了以后就用这种花瓣或者是
Katrina: Once they bloom, we can use the petals or...
Katrina:  我看他们压花
Katrina: I've seen people press flowers.
Katrina:  就是直接把这个花骨朵花剪下来
Katrina: Just cut the flower buds and...
Katrina:  然后就直接这样压
Katrina: Then press them like this.
Katrina:  他就会变成一个那种平面的
Katrina: It will become a flat...
Katrina:  然后展开的那个花
Katrina: Then an open flower.
Katrina:  然后就可以坐在那种明信片
Katrina: Then you can put it on a postcard.
Katrina:  我买的那种明信片贺卡
Katrina: I bought some postcard greeting cards.
Katrina:  还有那个包括那个叫什么
Katrina: And also, what's it called...
Katrina:  那种亚克力双层玻璃
Katrina: Acrylic double-layer glass.
Katrina:  然后像像一个那种相框就可以
Katrina: Like a frame, you can...
Katrina:  送给别人然后一些叶子啊什么的
Katrina: Give it to someone, and some leaves, and other things.
Katrina:  然后当时想的是
Katrina: So I was thinking...
Katrina:  你不是有那个户外活动吗
Katrina: You have that outdoor activity, right?
Katrina:  我们就可以去捡一些叶子
Katrina: We can pick some leaves.
Katrina:  然后就把它拼成一幅画一样的
Katrina: And arrange them into a picture.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yes
Katrina:  然后书签也有然后就大家自己做着玩
Katrina: And then we have bookmarks, so everyone can make their own and have fun.
Katrina:  然后最后一天
Katrina: And on the last day
Katrina:  因为想这种形式
Katrina: Because I want this kind of format
Katrina:  这种就邀请什么各种好朋友啊什么的
Katrina: This way we can invite all sorts of friends and such
Katrina:  就可以你自己做的自己养的
Katrina: You can use what you made and grew yourself
Katrina:  然后分发给大家就挺好
Katrina: And then share it with everyone, which is great
Katrina:  然后也比较符合7天这个周期嘛
Katrina: It also fits well with this 7-day cycle
Alice: 嗯要不先给他醒了吧
Alice: Hmm, should we wake him up first?
Katrina:  嗯可以啊今天我肯今天是一定要
Katrina: Hmm, sure, today I definitely have to
Jake: 先聊吧这个回头下一个
Jake: Let's talk first, then we can do the next one
Katrina:  行下一个下一个谁
Katrina: Okay, who's next?
Alice: 下一个
Alice: Next one
Katrina: 我来弄这个
Katrina: I'll do this
Katrina:  下一个谁来
Katrina: Who's next?
Shure: 下一个 路路亚同学啊
Shure: Next one, Lulua
Shure: 露西
Shure: Lucia
Lucia: 啊其实就是我的构思
Lucia: Ah, actually it's my idea
Lucia: 也跟DIY是有关系的
Lucia: It’s related to DIY
Lucia: 对我刚我刚开始想的是
Lucia: Yeah, what I initially thought was
Lucia: 就是可以因为是世界地球日
Lucia: Since it's Earth Day
Lucia: 所以我想就是做一点环保一点的东西
Lucia: So I wanted to do something more eco-friendly
Lucia: 就我不知道大家有没有做过水母灯
Lucia: I don't know if you guys have made jellyfish lamps
Lucia: 就这两年在景区还挺火的
Lucia: They’ve been quite popular in scenic spots these past two years
Lucia: 呃就是长得像水母一样的一个小灯
Lucia: Uh, it's a small lamp that looks like a jellyfish
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right
Lucia: 然后这个东西它原本是有材料包的
Lucia: And this thing originally comes with a material kit
Lucia: 就是可以直接在网上买材料包做
Lucia: You can buy the kit online to make it
Lucia: 但是我就是我想的是
Lucia: But what I was thinking is
Lucia: 就是既然是世界地球日的话
Lucia: Since it’s Earth Day
Lucia: 我之前在网上刷到过一个教程
Lucia: I found a tutorial online before.
Lucia: 就是可以用那个奶茶杯盖
Lucia: You can use a bubble tea lid.
Lucia: 然后以它作为一个主体
Lucia: And use it as a base.
Lucia: 然后就是再加一些丝带
Lucia: Then add some ribbons.
Lucia: 或者串珠之类的
Lucia: Or beads or something.
Lucia: 呃我不知道咱们这有没有热热胶枪
Lucia: Uh, I'm not sure if we have a hot glue gun.
Lucia: 如果没有的话
Lucia: If not,
Lucia: 可以后面看有没有什么替代的
Lucia: We can look for alternatives later.
Lucia: 或者说买一个也行
Lucia: Or we can buy one.
Lucia: 然后就是大家一起
Lucia: And then everyone
Lucia: 就是每个人都做一个这样的小灯
Lucia: can make a little lamp like this.
Lucia: 就是它还挺好看的
Lucia: It's really pretty.
Lucia: 然后这是其中一个设想
Lucia: So that's one idea.
Lucia: 还有一个就是也是
Lucia: Another one is,
Lucia: 有点这种怎么说呢
Lucia: how should I say,
Lucia: 低碳和循环利用的
Lucia: more about low-carbon and recycling.
Lucia: 就是大家有没有做过纸箱小狗
Lucia: Has anyone made a cardboard dog?
Lucia: 就前段时间特别火那个啊
Lucia: It was really popular recently.
Katrina:  可以放在那个
Katrina: It can be placed
Lucia: 对然后可以放在门口
Lucia: Yeah, it can be placed at the door.
Lucia: 然后纸箱小狗的好处就是
Lucia: So, the great thing about cardboard dogs is,
Lucia: 如果想要很简单做一下的话
Lucia: if you want to make it simple,
Lucia: 就拿纸箱简单剪一下
Lucia: you just cut a cardboard box,
Lucia: 然后画一个小狗头粘上就可以
Lucia: and then draw a dog head and stick it on.
Lucia: 如果想要复杂一点的话
Lucia: If you want to make it more complex,
Lucia: 就是也有一些
Lucia: there are some options,
Lucia: 就是复杂点就需要多剪几个
Lucia: like cutting more pieces to make a bigger one.
Lucia: 然后做成一个大的
Lucia: I saw someone make a Doberman before.
Lucia: 我之前看到有人做过杜宾
Lucia: 但是那个我没做过就是
Lucia: But I haven't made that one,
Lucia: 但是就是看了一下教程
Lucia: I just saw the tutorial.
Lucia: 好像也挺简单的
Lucia: It seems pretty simple.
Lucia: 只要画一下卡纸就能很容易剪出来
Lucia: You just need to draw on the cardboard and cut it out easily.
Shure:  咱们最不缺的就是纸箱
Shure: We have plenty of cardboard boxes.
Shure:  所以我觉得这个
Shure: So, I think this is good.
Lucia: 对我当时想的也是
Lucia: That's what I thought too.
Lucia: 在咱们这里到时候肯定会有很多纸箱
Lucia: Here, we'll definitely have a lot of guidance.
Lucia: 如果说就能直接使用的话
Lucia: If we can use them directly,
Lucia: 就还挺环保的
Lucia: it's pretty eco-friendly.
Lucia: 就也很契合世界地球日这个主题
Lucia: It also fits the theme of Earth Day.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure: start
Shure: Start.
Lucia: 对然后最后还有一个想法
Lucia: Yeah, and lastly, I have one more idea.
Lucia: 但是这个想法实施起来就比较困难
Lucia: But it's a bit difficult to implement.
Lucia: 我本来想的是
Lucia: What I was thinking is,
Lucia: 可能大家可以简单的排一个小短剧
Lucia: maybe we could put together a short skit or something.
Lucia: 或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia: 对因为我之前跟我小伙伴有说
Lucia: Yeah, because I mentioned to my buddies before
Lucia: 我们今天拍一些微电影这种
Lucia: that we could shoot some short films today.
Tasha: 培养皿拍了吗
Lucia: 但是如果要排一个小短剧的话
Lucia: But if we want to do a skit,
Lucia: 就是我现在暂时还没有想到一个现成
Lucia: I haven't come up with a ready-to-use script yet.
Lucia: 我们目前就拿来用的剧本
Lucia: We don't have a script we can use right now.
Lucia: 因为咱们时间比较短
Lucia: Because we're short on time.
Tasha: 昨天给你的卡片等会拿出来一下
Lucia: 就如果要现在去编的话
Lucia: 可能就不太来得及
Lucia: we probably won't have enough time.
Jake: 好
Lucia: 就如果大家有想到什么
Lucia: So if anyone has any ideas,
Lucia: 你们以前看到过的短视频之类的
Lucia: like short videos you've seen before,
Lucia: 这种也可以
Lucia: Those would work too.
Lucia: 就如果有个现成的剧本
Lucia: If there's a ready-made script,
Lucia: 我觉得咱们可以尝试拍一下
Lucia: I think we could try filming it.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah, OK.
Shure:  OK 好
Shure: Yeah, OK.
Lucia: 这个是目前暂时的想法
Lucia: Alright, this is our temporary idea for now.
Shure:  这是Lucia
Shure: This is Lucia.
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is
Shure:  露西亚哈哈
Shure: Lucia, haha.
Lucia: 哦我们两个名字好像
Lucia: Oh, our names sound similar.
Alice: 你把她名写反了哎
Alice: You wrote his name backwards.
Katrina: 真的哎
Katrina: Really, they do.
Lucia: 刘Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Liu Alice, hahaha.
Jake:加一道加一道
Jake: Add another one, add another one.
Alice: 加一道就行
Alice: Just add another one directly.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Katrina:  完了就是那个变异来磕完染色体的
Katrina: Then it's that mutation that finishes off the chromosomes.
Jake: 对对对变异
Katrina: Yes, yes, the mutation.
Shure:  好家伙这俩你都有
Shure: Wow, you have both of them.
Shure:  是吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Really? Hahahaha
Shure:  塔莎
Shure: Tasha .
Tasha: OK上我的道具拿出来哈哈哈哈
Tasha: OK, take out my props, hahahaha.
Jake: 上道具BGM
Jake: Play the prop BGM.
Shure:  当当当当当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Shure:  当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun.
Lucia: 此处应有背景音乐哈哈
Lucia: There should be background music here, haha.
Shure:  他的道具为什么在你的行李箱里
Shure: Why are his props in your suitcase?
Jake: 啊因为又是代言人
Jake: Ah, because he's the spokesperson again.
Tasha: 不就这个
Tasha: Isn't it just this one?
Tasha: 就这个啊
Tasha: Just this one.
Tasha: 你怎么没拆
Tasha: Why didn't you unpack it?
Tasha: 我去拿现成的吧
Tasha: I'll go get the ready-made one.
Tasha: 你去把培养皿拿出来吧
Shure:  培养皿
Shure: Petri dish.
Jake:培养皿
Jake: Petri dish.
Jake: 培养皿买了
Jake: I bought the petri dish.
Jake: 但是不一定到了
Jake: But it might not have arrived.
Jake: 不一定到哈
Jake: It might not have arrived yet.
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Tasha: 好像没有别的种类
Tasha: Seems like there are no other types.
Katrina:  可以装在这种里面
Katrina: You can put it in this kind.
Katrina:  我看一下
Katrina: Let me check.
Katrina:  弄出来特别漂亮
Katrina: It looks really pretty when taken out.
Shure:  你这是相框
Shure: Is this an incense frame?
Katrina:  对就把花夹在里面
Katrina: Yes, just clip the flowers inside.
Katrina:  还有一些叶子什么的可以摆在家里
Katrina: And some leaves and stuff, you can display them at home.
Katrina:  这确实这怎么雾蒙蒙的
Katrina: Indeed, why is it so foggy?
Katrina:  他中间应该夹了一层东西
Katrina: He probably put something in the middle.
Jake: 被嫌弃了
Jake: Feeling rejected.
Jake: 我应该拆吗
Jake: Should I open it?
Tasha: 然后哈哈
Tasha: And then haha,
Tasha: 就是这是
Tasha: so this is
Tasha: 自己设计的一些种子纸
Tasha: some seed paper I designed myself.
Tasha: 就是把种子放在这个纸里面
Tasha: You put the seeds inside this paper.
Tasha: 这个纸是用废弃的咖啡渣
Tasha: The paper is made from recycled coffee grounds,
Tasha: 呃一些纸
Tasha: uh, some paper,
Tasha: 然后做成那种纸浆
Tasha: and then turned into pulp.
Tasha: 然后纸浆里面有那种乳
Tasha: The pulp contains the seeds.
Tasha: 种子都是用的太阳花种子
Tasha: The seeds are sunflower seeds.
Tasha: 太阳花种子它比较容易发芽
Tasha: Sunflower seeds sprout easily.
Tasha: 然后如果用培养皿水培的话
Tasha: If you use a petri dish with water,
Tasha: 大概5天左右就可以发芽
Tasha: they can sprout in about 5 days.
Tasha: 然后做了一些种类的
Tasha: And then I made some types of...
Tasha: 算世界地球日吗
Jake: 那可地球了
Jake: Yeah, definitely Earth Day.
Alice: 这是你自己做的吗
Jake: Did you make this yourself?
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: So impressive.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  好厉害
Katrina: Awesome!
Tasha: 然后做了5种
Tasha: And then we made five kinds.
Tasha: 地球的
Tasha: Of the earth's.
Tasha: 然后做了两种很简单的
Tasha: And then we made two really simple ones.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 但是你是原创哎
Lucia: But yours is original!
Jake: 有点强
Jake: Pretty strong.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 种子片种子片
Jake: Seed film.Seed film
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: huh.
Shure:  种子片
Shure: Seed film.
Jake:种子片
Jake: Seed film.
Tasha: 嗯然后这样就比较环保嗯 吧
Tasha: Yeah, and that makes it more eco-friendly.
Katrina:  嗯真的很环保
Katrina: Hmm, it's really eco-friendly.
Lucia: 真的很环保
Lucia: Really eco-friendly.
Katrina:  而且还极具美感好吗
Katrina: And it's also very aesthetic, okay?
Tasha: 1234 好
Tasha: 1234, okay.
Jake: 那你自己设计的
Jake: Did you design it yourself?
Alice:嗯对我也去拿一下我的东西
Alice: Yeah, I'll go get my stuff too.
Jake: 是画的图吗
Jake: Is it a drawing?
Tasha: 啊这很简单了
Tasha: Ah, this is easy.
Tasha: 就找一些logo
Tasha: Just find some logos.
Tasha: 然后这个logo一找
Tasha: And once you find the logo,
Tasha: 写个字框个框就行了
Tasha: Write some text and frame it.
Jake: OK
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 挺好的挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: Very impressive.
Katrina:  种子卡片
Katrina: Seed cards.
Katrina:  然后呢就是嗯
Katrina: And then, um...
Alice: 买了一个拼图
Alice: I bought a puzzle.
Alice: 是一个呃大底层是一个圆的
Alice: It's a, um, the base is a big circle.
Alice: 然后它那个里面是这种的
Alice: And inside, it's like this.
Alice: 就是各种动物的那种
Alice: With all kinds of animals.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:然后你看你能不能
Alice: And then you see if you can
Alice: 就是一个比较难的一个拼图
Alice: It's a relatively difficult puzzle.
Alice: 然后有很多种动物
Alice: With many kinds of animals.
Alice: 我想的就是呃你去尽力的往里面拼
Alice: What I think is, um, you try to fit them in.
Alice: 就是我觉得这个拼图就给人一种
Alice: I think this puzzle gives people a sense
Alice: 我们在地球上
Alice: That on this Earth,
Alice: 可以和谐共处的那个感觉
Alice: We can coexist harmoniously.
Tasha: 嗯不用啦谢谢
Tasha: No need, thank you.
Alice: 然后你不一定全都能拼上
Alice: And you might not fit them all in.
Alice: 但是因为这种不是那个严丝合缝
Alice: Because it's not perfectly seamless.
Alice: 不是特别完全严丝合缝
Alice: Not perfectly seamless.
Alice: 就是说你可以拼多一点
Alice: So you can fit more,
Alice: 也可以拼少一点
Alice: Or fit fewer.
Alice: 然后我就想
Alice: And I just thought
Alice: 呃可能就是一个小的游戏吧
Alice: Um, maybe it's just a small game.
Jake: 头头发
Jake: Hair, hair.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:要不
Jake: Or...
Jake: 要不夹进去
Jake: Or we could clip it.
Lucia: 有没有夹子
Lucia: Do we have a clip?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 然后就是
Shure: And then...
Alice: 我就想给参与者就是一个小奖品
Alice: I just want to give the participants a little prize.
Alice: 就是一颗水仙种球
Alice: It's a daffodil bulb.
Alice: 因为这个水仙种球它好养
Alice: Because this daffodil bulb is easy to take care of.
Alice: 就是呃
Alice: Like, uh...
Alice: 在我的那种植物杀手朋友身上
Alice: I tested it on my friends who are plant killers.
Alice: 试验过了
Alice: Even they can keep it alive.
Alice: 他都能养活的东西
Alice: And the flowers are really beautiful.
Alice: 然后这个花开出来也特别的好看
Alice: Plus, it has a nice fragrance.
Alice: 然后还有清香的味道
Alice: And you can watch it grow day by day.
Alice: 并且你看着他一天天长大
Alice: It gives you that feeling of participating in nature.
Alice: 你很有那种参与自然的感觉
Alice: So that's my idea.
Alice: 对所以这就是我的想法
Alice: But I haven't bought the daffodil bulbs yet.
Alice: 但是水仙球还没买
Alice: But I know where to get really good ones.
Alice: 但是我有
Alice: But I have...
Alice: 我知道有一家质量特别好的
Alice: I know a place with really good quality ones.
Alice: 我养过的就是
Alice: I've raised some from there.
Alice: 有需要他可以直接买过来
Alice: If needed, we can buy from them directly.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Jake: 好
Jake: 仙球
Jake: Daffodil bulb.
Shure:  活动内容现在有4个
Shure: We have 4 activities now.
Shure:  到谁了
Shure: Whose turn is it?
Alice: 不是到我了吗
Alice: Isn't it my turn?
Shure:  野生动物拼图
Shure: Wildlife puzzle.
Katrina:  哎我还想让我第一天吃海底捞
Katrina: Oh, I was thinking about my first day at Haidilao.
Katrina:  送了我一个种草莓的那个盆栽
Katrina: They gave me a strawberry planting kit.
Katrina:  也可以种一下
Katrina: You can grow them too.
Jake:海底捞
Jake: Haidilao.
Tasha: 那那个豌豆还可以种
Tasha: Then we can still plant those peas.
Katrina:  对还可以种啊
Katrina: Yes, we can still plant them.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina:  海底捞就最近不是跟樱桃小丸子联名
Katrina: Recently, Haidilao collaborated with Chibi Maruko-chan.
Katrina:  点他那个东西他就送你那个盆栽
Katrina: If you order their stuff, they give you a potted plant.
Katrina:  哦这么好
Katrina: Oh, that's nice.
Lucia: 嗯我草莓宿舍摆
Lucia: Hmm, I'll put it in my strawberry dorm.
Katrina:  我说他咋知道我要过来种东西
Katrina: I was wondering how they knew I wanted to plant something.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  我当时本来想买盆栽来着
Katrina: I was planning to buy a potted plant.
Katrina:  想盆栽要一个月才能发芽
Katrina: I heard it takes a month for it to sprout.
Jake: 走上海边种树去
Jake: Let's go plant trees by the sea.
Shure:  然后到我了
Shure: Then it's my turn.
Jake:到您了
Jake: Your turn.
Shure:  我的是一个
Shure: I have one...
Shure:  一个类似于二手拍卖的
Shure: One idea that's sort of like a second-hand auction.
Shure:  一个一个一个一个一个一个一个想法
Shure: It's an idea, an idea, an idea, an idea...
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  大家平时会不会去一些什么
Shure: Do you guys often go to places like...
Shure:  比如说小小小酒馆啊
Shure: Like small bars, or...
Shure:  或者是咖啡店
Shure: Or coffee shops.
Shure:  就那种比较有烟火气的地方
Shure: Places that have a cozy, lived-in feel.
Shure:  然后之前那个
Shure: And previously, there was...
Shure:  北京有一个连锁的精酿啤酒
Shure: A chain of craft beer places in Beijing.
Shure:  叫跳海
Shure: Called Tiaohai.
Katrina: 哦我知道在什刹海那是不是
Katrina: Oh, I know, it's in Shichahai, right?
Shure:  对什刹海应该是这个吧
Shure: Yes, it should be in Shichahai.
Jake: 然后指的是这个吗
Jake: And you mean this one?
Shure:  其其他城市也有
Shure: They also have it in other cities.
Tasha: 哪个
Jake: 你刚刚是让我拿这个吗
Shure:  什么市场也有
Shure: And other markets too.
Shure:  然后他们前两天大榕寺开业的时候
Shure: Recently, when they opened Dazong Temple...
Tasha: 我想让你帮我把这拿出来
Shure:  他们搞了一个
Shure: They did something...
Jake: 结果我拿错东西了
Shure:  就是类似于这个拍卖的
Shure: Like an auction.
Jake: 对不起
Shure:  一个一个一个形式吧
Shure: A kind of format.
Tasha: 这就一封吗
Shure:  然后就是
Shure: And then...
Jake: 嗯
Tasha: 我说我的明信片就只有一份吗
Tasha: I only have one postcard of mine, right?
Shure:  他们当时是你喝酒会给你一个币
Shure: Back then, if you drank, they'd give you a token.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: 不知道啊
Jake: You know that?
Shure: 然后用这个币
Shure: And then with this token...
Shure:  来买大家的一些任何的东西
Shure: You could buy everyone's stuff.
Shure:  可以是一个是是一个诗集
Shure: It could be a poetry collection.
Shure:  可以是一个故事
Shure: It could be a story.
Shure:  然后也可以是一个
Shure: Or it could be an actual item.
Shure:  就是真实存在的一个物品
Shure: And then everyone...
Shure:  然后就每人
Shure: Every item had a small PPT.
Shure:  就是那个每个物品都做一个小的PPT
Shure: And then they'd present it.
Shure:  然后展示出来
Shure: And show it off.
Katrina: 啊还要做ppt吗
Katrina: Oh, you even had to make a PPT?
Shure:  然后然后然后哈哈哈哈
Shure: And then, and then, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这是工作狂游戏吗
Lucia: Is this a workaholic game?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 啊不然后然
Shure: Oh and then...
Shure:  后然后
Shure: And then...
Shure:  然后然后
Shure:  然后就是一个拍卖吧
Shure: Then there was an auction.
Shure:  然后我们可以怎么样呢
Shure: And we could, you know...
Shure:  就是来的这些嘉宾
Shure: Invite the guests...
Shure:  然后大家一人分享一个故事
Shure: And everyone would share a story.
Shure:  或者是呃
Shure: Or, um...
Shure:  事故也好
Shure: An incident, or...
Shure:  故事也好
Shure: A story.
Shure:  然后来我们给评定
Shure: And then we would evaluate...
Shure:  觉得这个故事怎么样
Shure: And see how good the story was.
Jake: 值多少个币是吧
Jake: See how many tokens it's worth, right?
Shure:  对值多少个币
Shure: Yeah, how many tokens.
Shure:  然后给他
Shure: And then give them...
Shure:  然后这个币
Shure: And then these tokens...
Tasha: 像什么
Tasha: Like what?
Tasha: 一个故事换一根藤条的那种
Tasha: Like trading a story for a vine stick or something?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  然后这个币就用来拍卖
Shure: Then this currency will be used for auction.
Shure:  接下来这些嘉宾带来的二手物品
Shure: Next, these guests will bring their second-hand items.
Shure:  以及是我们就是闲置的一些二手物品
Shure: As well as some of our own unused second-hand items.
Shure:  然后来进行这样的一个交换
Shure: And then we will do this kind of exchange.
Shure:  就是
Shure: That is
Shure:  也是跟这个环保理念比较比较挂钩的
Shure: Also, this ties in with the environmental concept.
Shure:  行大概就是这个样子
Shure: So that's basically it.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Wonderful.
Katrina:  就是讲故事
Katrina: So, telling stories.
Katrina:  换了币然后就可以购买
Katrina: Exchange the currency and then you can buy.
Katrina:  购买他们自己带来的闲置物品嘛
Katrina: Buy the unused items they brought.
Shure:  每个人拍
Shure: Each person auctions
Shure:  拍卖就是比如说我
Shure: Auctions, for example, if I
Shure:  我要卖一个什么东西
Shure: Want to sell something
Shure:  然后我上来讲一下这个东西
Shure: Then I come up and talk about it
Shure:  然后我认为他的起拍价大概多少
Shure: And then I think its starting bid is about this much
Shure:  然后拍到这个钱
Shure: Then the money from the auction
Shure:  是给到那个拍卖的那个人的
Shure: Goes to the person who auctioned it.
Shure:  然后他也流通过去那个货币
Shure: And then they circulate the currency.
Shure:  然后我拿着这些货币
Shure: And I take the currency
Shure:  我可以再去拍卖
Shure: I can go to the auction again.
Katrina:  你再去买别的
Katrina: And buy something else.
Shure:  对剩下的
Shure: Yeah, the remaining stuff.
Alice: 反正就是换了一种交流的货币
Alice: So basically we are just exchanging a different kind of currency.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina:  也构建了我们整个的经济体系
Katrina: It also builds our entire economic system.
Katrina:  哈哈哈货币流通
Katrina: Hahaha currency circulation.
Tasha: OK那我就看看这些了
Tasha: OK, then I'll see how this works.
Katrina: 我们都是那个市场的内部了
Katrina: We are all part of this market.
Shure:  对可以把
Shure: Yeah, we can put
Tasha: 收好
Shure:  这些
Katrina:  我们都是
Alice: 赚币的
Alice: Earning currency.
Katrina:  他是他是搞货币流通的
Katrina: He's all about currency circulation.
Lucia: 可以做一些手工艺品
Lucia: You can make some handicrafts
Lucia: 用来用来拍卖
Lucia: For auctioning.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Katrina:  就我们做这个
Katrina: We can do this.
Jake: 就我们平台方做这个
Jake: We, the platform, can do this.
Katrina:  也可以
Katrina: That's fine too.
Jake:平台方和小店
Jake: The platform and the small store.
Jake: 小店家
Jake: The small store.
Katrina: 对哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Yes, haha.
Shure:  今天就是这样的形式
Shure: That's the format for today.
Tasha: 这是我的商品
Tasha: These are my products.
Tasha: 我要拍卖了嘿嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: I'm auctioning them.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  还有什么想法吗
Shure: Any other ideas?
Shure:  大家
Shure: Everyone.
Katrina: 我看看啊
Katrina: Let me see.
Katrina:  在那一天邀请他
Katrina: Invite them on that day.
Katrina:  们过来这是我们准备的一些嗯东东西
Katrina: This is some stuff we prepared.
Katrina:  那怎么招待他们要不要搞一点什么
Katrina: How should we entertain them? Should we do something special?
Katrina:  就像我我我经常我们学校草坪发
Katrina: Like, at my school, on the lawn,
Katrina:  他们会自己调酒
Katrina: They make their own drinks.
Katrina:  就自己自己
Katrina: Just themselves.
Katrina:  人多的时候就有点像那种小party一样
Katrina: When there are many people, it's like a small party.
Katrina: 可以在外面
Katrina: We can do it outside.
Shure:  啊我可以可以给大家冲咖啡
Shure: Ah, I can make coffee for everyone.
Shure:  我那有有一套手冲的东西哈哈
Shure: I have a whole set for making hand-brewed coffee, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  对就是可以请大家喝点东西
Katrina: Yes, we can serve drinks to everyone.
Shure:  笑的这么开心
Shure: Laughing so happily.
Jake: 突然开心了起来
Jake: Suddenly got happy.
Lucia: 支持
Lucia: Support.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Katrina: 就表演
Katrina: Just perform.
Shure: c加a coffee and alcohol
Shure: C plus A, coffee and alcohol.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Is it okay?
Katrina:  对那就是整个活动
Katrina: Yeah, that's the whole event.
Katrina:  那一天大概持续多长时间
Katrina: So, how long does it usually last?
Jake: 一下午呗
Jake: An afternoon.
Katrina:  一下午
Katrina: An afternoon.
Katrina:  嗯那就给他们提供一些饮品就够了吧
Katrina: Hmm, so just providing some drinks should be enough, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 先饮品然后我们就有点像
Katrina: Drinks first, then we have something like...
Katrina:  这这算市级部分
Katrina: This counts as the city part.
Katrina:  然后饮品部分也有了
Katrina: And the drinks part is settled.
Katrina:  那是不是还要什么节目啊您之前
Katrina: Should we also have some programs or something?
Jake: 嗯对可以
Jake: Hmm, yeah, we could.
Jake: 嗯或者最后一天应该是从中午
Jake: Hmm, or on the last day, it should start from noon.
Jake: 中午管不管饭
Jake: Are we providing lunch?
Jake: 这个另说
Jake: That's another matter.
Jake: 也可以管也可以不管共多少个人
Jake: We could provide it or not. How many people are there altogether?
Katrina:  好像
Katrina: Seems like...
Katrina:  不用管饭但是可以请他做一点点甜的
Katrina: We don't need to provide lunch, but we can offer some sweets.
Jake: 对对对下午茶
Jake: Yes, yes, afternoon tea.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Jake:嗯对那就是不用管饭
Jake: Yes, so no need to provide lunch.
Jake: 大家吃完饭过来
Jake: Everyone comes after lunch.
Jake: 然后时间线我们捏一下
Jake: Then we'll adjust the timeline a bit.
Jake: 如果是下午开始两点比如说或者3点
Jake: If we start in the afternoon, like at 2 PM or 3 PM...
Jake: 3点一直干到晚上之类的
Jake: From 3 PM till the evening or something.
Katrina:  可以干到晚上但是天气怎么样
Katrina: We can go till the evening, but how's the weather?
Jake: 这个就不知道了
Jake: That's unknown,
Katrina: 我看会不会下雨
Katrina: We'll see if it rains.
Katrina:  不下雨的话如果像今天这种天的话
Katrina: If it doesn't rain, and the weather is like today...
Katrina:  弄到晚上还是挺漂亮的嗯
Katrina: Doing it till evening would be quite beautiful, hmm.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 对今天下午的话
Jake: Yes, this afternoon...
Jake: 这个小院子应该也挺舒服的
Jake: This little braid should also be quite comfortable.
Jake: 你还还可以烧烤
Jake: You can also have a barbecue.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Definitely.
Jake: 买签了吗
Jake: Did you buy the skewers?
Shure:  还没呢
Shure: Not yet,
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 我今天一起购入
Shure: I'll buy it all today.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 还要买碳的签碳肉
Jake: We also need to buy skewers, charcoal,
Shure: 这些
Shure:  and meat.
Shure:  其实就是外卖都有其实可以当日达的
Shure: Actually, you can get all of these through delivery, same-day service.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Jake: 行行
Jake: Sure, sure.
Katrina:  21号
Katrina: On the 21st.
Shure:  大家平时厨艺如何
Shure: How's everyone's cooking skills?
Shure:  就是会使用刀吗
Shure: Like, can you use a knife?
Katrina: 会啊
Katrina: Yeah, I can.
Jake: 会比较会使用
Jake: I can use it quite well.
Tasha: 我还行呵呵
Tasha: I'm okay, hehe.
Shure:  能切个肉什么的吗
Shure: Can you cut meat or something?
修老板: 能切都能切吧
Jack: We can all cut, right?
Jake: 都能切
Jake: We can all cut.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:各位都能切了
Jake: Everyone can cut.
Shure:  有大家这句话我就放心了
Shure: With everyone's assurance, I'm relieved.
Jake: 因为你不切
Jake: Because you don't cut.
Lucia: 稍微冷藏一下
Lucia: Slightly chill it.
Lucia: 然后拿出来稍微放一会的时候好切
Lucia: Then take it out and let it sit for a bit, it's easier to cut.
Lucia: 嗯如果是软的肉我不是很会切
Lucia: Hmm, if it's soft meat, I'm not very good at cutting it.
Lucia: 就已经化好的那种明白
Lucia: Like when it's already thawed, you know.
Shure: 明白
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
Jake: 行可以烤是吧
Jake: Okay, we can grill, right?
Shure:  可以烤
Shure: We can grill.
Jake:长春烤串
Jake: Changchun skewers.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  其实调酒好像就是买买一点那种啤酒
Katrina: Actually, for cocktails, just get some beer.
Shure: 啤酒
Shure: Beer.
Katrina:  对然后搞一点冰块
Katrina: Yeah, and some ice.
Shure:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  冰块的话
Shure: As for ice...
Katrina:  哎我现在前面我们走两步
Katrina: Hey, let's walk a few steps ahead.
Katrina:  不是有个咖啡厅
Katrina: Isn't there a café?
Katrina:  能不能问他们借点冰块
Katrina: Can we ask them for some ice?
Katrina:  就不用自己买制冰机了
Katrina: So we don't have to buy an ice machine.
Shure:  可以
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 我们花钱买点冰块
Katrina: We'll pay for some ice.
Shure:  那边有咖啡厅吗
Shure: Is there a café over there?
Katrina:  对啊昨天停车那位置
Katrina: Yeah, where we parked yesterday.
Lucia: 如果我们要求不那么高的话
Lucia: If we don't need anything fancy,
Lucia: 就是买一个冰膜然后自己冻一下
Lucia: we can just buy an ice mold and freeze it ourselves.
Lucia: 也可以啊
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia: 只不过就是冻出来可能没有
Lucia: It might not be as good, but...
Katrina:  哎我们有透明
Katrina: Hey, we have a clear...
Katrina:  我们有冰箱
Katrina: We have a fridge.
Katrina:  就买个那个模具倒点水
Katrina: Just buy the mold and fill it with water.
Katrina:  前天晚上冻一下
Katrina: Freeze it overnight.
Alice: 用蒸馏水就行
Alice: Just use distilled water.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:就煮过煮沸的水
Alice: Just boiled water.
Lucia: 哦可以
Lucia: Oh, that works.
Shure:  蒸馏水对
Shure: Distilled water, yeah.
Shure:  可还行呵呵呵
Shure: That works, haha.
Shure:  我们到底是在搞什么
Shure: What are we even doing?
Shure:  搞实验了是吗
Shure: Are we running an experiment?
Katrina:  那他整整体的时间流程呢
Katrina: So what's the overall schedule?
Jake: 比如说我们从入场3点3点开始吧
Jake: For example, we start at 3 PM.
Katrina:  几点到几点干什么
Jake: What's the plan for each time slot?
Katrina: What's the plan for each time slot?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 因为就5个人
Katrina: Because we only have five people.
Katrina:  就有一点像那种市集
Katrina: It's a bit like those markets.
Katrina:  但是那种市集一般都是比较大
Katrina: But those markets are usually bigger.
Katrina:  然后大家随意逛
Katrina: And people just wander around.
Katrina:  但是我们这个地方比较小
Katrina: But our place is smaller.
Katrina:  那你肯定要规定一定的时间干什么
Katrina: So you definitely need to schedule specific times for things.
Katrina:  一定的时间干什么
Katrina: Specific times for things.
Katrina:  要不然容易他们一下就看完了
Katrina: Otherwise, they'll finish looking around too quickly.
Jake: 对你的拍卖可以占一点时间
Jake: Yeah, your auction can take up some time.
Jake: 看占多长时间
Jake: Let's see how long it takes.
Jake: 然后
Jake: Then...
Jake: 唉
Jake: Oh...
Jake: 就这些准备都是我们这几天准备对吧
Jake: All these preparations were done in the past few days, right?
Jake: 然后别的耗时间的短剧
Jake: And other time-consuming short plays.
Jake: 跳舞吗哈哈哈
Jake: Dance? Hahaha
Lucia:  哈哈我一个人跳吗
Lucia: Hahaha, should I dance alone?
Katrina:  可以排一个简单的
Katrina: We can choreograph a simple one.
Jake: 以前也可以跳
Katrina: I used to be able to dance too.
Katrina:  可以排个稍微简单点的
Katrina: We can choreograph a simpler one.
Jake:硕也可以跳
Jake: Shure can dance too.
Lucia: 哦那也行对
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Katrina:  短片
Lucia: 你如果有现成的剧本的话
Lucia: If you have a ready script.
Lucia: 我们可以拍一个哈哈哈
Lucia: We can shoot one, hahaha.
Shure:  演其实有有点小尬
Shure: Acting is kind of awkward.
Katrina:   嗯不如跳舞
Katrina: Hmm, dancing is better.
Katrina:  因为那个音乐放上了
Katrina: Because when the music plays...
Katrina:  不如跳舞
Katrina: Dancing is better.
Alice: 谈恋爱不如跳舞哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Falling in love is not as good as dancing.
Shure:  不如跳舞
Shure: How about dancing?
Shure:  捋一下时间线吧
Shure: Let's sort out the timeline.
Lucia: 可是跳舞的话戴眼镜会掉耶
Shure: But if we dance, the glasses might fall off.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 还戴眼镜那时候
Shure: We were still wearing glasses back then.
Shure:  那我们可以挑点简单的
Shure: Then we can pick something simple.
Shure:  蘑菇蘑菇哎
Shure: Mushroom, mushroom, hey.
Lucia:  我们可以跳抖音上的那种
Lucia: We can do those TikTok dances.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure:  这个听我说
Shure: Listen to me.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 抖音上就大家都可以一起挑
Lucia: On TikTok, everyone can join in.
Lucia: 就是排的时间也会短一些对吧
Lucia: And the time it takes to arrange it will be shorter, right?
Lucia: 也没有什么比较大的动作
Lucia: There aren't any big movements.
Lucia: 戴眼镜也不影响
Lucia: Glasses won't be an issue.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure:  捋下时间线
Shure: Let's sort out the timeline.
Tasha: 可拍满100个硬币
Tasha: We could auction off 100 coins.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  你那个
Katrina: Yours...
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Tasha: 我只是觉得应该拍卖实硬银币
Tasha: I just think we should auction off 10 silver coins.
Jake:哦好好可以买够
Jake: Oh, okay, we can buy that.
Katrina:  哦哦不对
Katrina: Oh, wait, no.
Katrina:  拍卖之前首先要他们讲故事
Katrina: Before the auction, they need to tell a story first.
Katrina:  才能获得那个币
Katrina: Then they can get the coins.
Jake: 对对对就是这个时间
Jake: Yes, yes, that's the time.
Jake: 可能就得放一个半小时了
Jake: It might take an hour and a half.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 就就你们昨天的那个活动
Jake: Just like your event yesterday.
Jake: 也也
Jake: And, and...
Shure: 也不用讲那么长
Shure: No need to make it that long.
Shure:  就讲一个小故事
Shure: Just tell a short story.
Shure:  一个每个人5分钟那种大概
Shure: Like, each person gets about 5 minutes.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Shure:  或者时间成本控制不好的话
Shure: Or if we can't manage the time cost well...
Shure:  就以其他形式获得币
Shure: We could get the currency in other ways.
Shure:  但是这个活动的核心是那个拍卖过程
Shure: But the core of this event is the auction process.
Shure:  但是这个货币怎么获得
Shure: As for how to get the currency...
Shure:  可以再进一步上去
Shure: We can refine that further.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 拍卖过程这个是要保留的
Shure: The auction process must be kept.
Shure:  大概像9个人的话每个人5分钟
Shure: If there are about 9 people, each with 5 minutes...
Shure:  5945一个小时吧
Shure: 45 minutes, roughly an hour.
Shure:  就按一个小时算的
Shure: Let's calculate it as an hour.
Lucia: 我给大家发一些币
Lucia: I'll give everyone some currency.
Lucia: 然后通过摇骰子让大家玩一会
Lucia: Then, let everyone play for a bit with dice.
Katrina: 这这像游戏
Katrina: This feels like a game.
Jake: 对对对
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:呵整点游戏可以
Jake: Haha, playing games is fine.
Shure:  我们门门口再来一个
Jake: We could do it at our entrance.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没有没有开个玩笑
Lucia: No, no, just kidding.
Lucia: 可以可以可以
Katrina: It's fine, very fun.
Katrina:  没关系很快乐
Katrina:  确实啊
Katrina: Indeed.
Lucia: 这个听起来有点
Katrina: This sounds a bit...
Lucia: 哈哈哈一会发鸡蛋一会摇色子
Lucia: Haha, sometimes handing out eggs, sometimes rolling dice.
Jake:哈哈哈哈据点是吧
Jake: Hahaha, it's like a base, right?
Shure: 一锅端了
Shure: Wiped out everyone at once.
Tasha: 进来玩玩嘛
Tasha: Come in and play.
Tasha: 进来就可以获得10个币
Tasha: You get 10 coins just for coming in.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 哈哈
Katrina:  但是一一进来就让
Katrina: But once they come in...
Katrina:  就是刚开始肯定要获得货币
Katrina: At the beginning, they definitely have to get some coins.
Katrina:  但是你获得货币
Katrina: But to get the coins...
Katrina:  是要他们通过讲故事的方式
Katrina: They have to tell stories.
Katrina:  但是他们一进来可能还没那么熟
Katrina: But they might not be that familiar once they come in.
Katrina:  就要让他们在众人面前讲故事干什么
Katrina: And then you want them to tell stories in front of everyone?
Tasha: 那就自我介绍
Tasha: Then just do self-introductions.
Katrina:  会冷场
Katrina: It might be awkward.
Alice:可以获得一个币啊
Alice: You get a coin.
Lucia: 啊自我介绍可以获得
Lucia: Ah, self-introduction can get...
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Katrina: 啊自我介绍可以获得
Katrina: Ah, self-introduction can get...
Jake:自我介绍获得或者
Jake: Self-introduction can get, or...
Alice: 第一个给5个
Alice: The first one gets 5.
Jake: 获得第一个给5个
Alice: 第二个给仨
Alice: The second gets 3.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Katrina:  养成机制
Katrina: Nurturing mechanism
Jake: 或者我们其实在这个屋子里面
Jake: Or actually in this room
Jake: 可以藏点东西
Jake: We can hide some stuff
Jake: 然后
Jake: And then
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 像复活节的那种寻彩蛋游戏一样
Lucia: Like an Easter egg hunt game
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: 藏点币
Jake: Hide some coins
Shure:  藏币
Shure: Hide coins
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 也行
Shure: That could work
Tasha: 那
Katrina:  就是刚开始自我介绍或者币
Katrina: Just starting with self-introduction or coins
Katrina:  然后玩玩点小游戏赢赢了的币
Katrina: Then play some mini-games to win coins
Shure:  对就比如说
Shure: Yeah, for example
Katrina: 说一些问答什么的
Katrina: Some Q&A or something
Shure:  野生动物拼图那个
Shure: Like the wildlife puzzle one
Lucia:  哎问答的话反正是世界地球日
Lucia: Yeah, Q&A, since it's Earth Day
Lucia: 对可以
Lucia: Yeah, that works
Katrina:  知识问
Katrina: Trivia questions
Lucia: 对答知识问答
Lucia: Yeah, trivia questions
Shure:  知识问答得币
Shure: Trivia questions to earn coins
Shure:  对对对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Good
Tasha: 世界地球日
Shure: World's first
Tasha: 在哪一天
Tasha: On what day
Katrina: 先要把那个
Lucia: 二十几来着22 22
Jake: 22
Jake: 22nd
Katrina: 钱给让他们得到
Katrina: Let them get it on
Jake:21来着
Jake: 21st
Katrina:  然后再开始推销
Katrina: Then let's start promoting.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 推销我们的产品
Katrina: Promote our product.